mummies with Caucasian features found in
China it's a discovery that could change
history did Westerners make it to China
more than 3,000 years before Marco Polo
there are probably only a handful of
vines of this nature in every century it
is too good to be true it's too
interesting a mystery only the most
advanced forensic tools of the 21st
century can solve what is their story
where did they come from and who were
just unwrapping them requires great care
but what they plan to do next is even
more delicate operating on the 38
hundred year old corpse of the beauty of
Lola
I have learned that when you are working
with DNA you really need to show your
respect for the people behind it we
basically like if all of us stood in
front of the mummy for I don't know for
like a three or four hours without doing
anything we hesitated to our hands over
I was very much surprised by the texture
of the skins they literally became
lather
- oh you can toy
their first attempt
dry brittle a sample unlikely to contain
intact DNA Holanda I was a very
depressed very much depressed especially
for the beauty of lowland I thought that
well probably wouldn't be able to get
anything from the mummies they would
have to keep trying more mummies a young
boy like the beauty of Lola he is one of
the older mummies dating as far back as
2000 BC as much as she he speaks of the
difficult lives of these people
he is among many children found buried
in the Tarim basin almost one third of
the corpses found had died before
reaching adulthood
but in death he would help provide clues
investigators found in the vicinity of
the boy artifacts that mystified them
small fragments with big implications
bronze it's an amalgam of metals copper
and tin common today but in its time one
of the great inventions of human history
first thought to be used in ancient
Mesopotamia around 3500 BC bronze had
spread from one group to the next until
it engulfed the globe it was a
revolutionary technology
giving rise to new tools and weapons
technology that had significant impact
on every culture that encountered it and
here it was next to a boy one of the
things that bothered me so much about
the mummies is it that the technologies
they had were too advanced for the time
here we have mummies back a thousand
eight hundred BC with bronze and this is
before it was in China some believe that
the Chinese invented bronze on their own
uninfluenced by the outside world
but could the Tarim people have brought
bronze to the Chinese
Braun's may have been a key to survival
in this environment but for many that
would not be enough then as now hard
work malnutrition and disease would take
its toll on children first